もう一行読みます ディソディサンヤンタンカイラ
ヴェーリワパナヴェーリナン
ミッチャパニータンチッタン
パピヨナンタトウカレエ
ディソディサンヤンタンカイラ
ヴェーリワパナヴェーリナン
ミッチャパニータンチッタン
パピヨナンタトウカレエ
ディソディサンヤンタンカイラ
ヤンタンカイラというのは何かするでしょうということでね
するであろうと ディソっていうのは敵が
ディサン 敵に何をするでしょうという意味ですね
それで敵が敵に何をするでしょうと
で この場合はちょっと計算しないといけない
で 例えば私が ある人は敵だと思っている
しかし その人は私を敵だと思っているということじゃないでしょうし
あんたは敵だと私は言っただけで
私もあなたの敵だということはないでしょうに
それで私が誰かさんが敵やと思うのは
私はその人に対してすごい恨みを持ってるんだからなんです
そこで相手も私も敵だと
私も敵だと思ったら その人は私に対してすごい恨みを持ってるんです
例えば 息子が母が敵だと思っても
母が息子は敵やと思ってないでしょうに
その時喧嘩になっても
その喧嘩と互いにすごい敵同士だったらどうするのかと
これ 互いに恨みを持っている敵同士なんですね
で 相手が私は敵だと思わなくても
私が相手が敵やと思っている場合
私は一方的にその人を殴ったり殺したりはする
しかし 私は出ていかない限りは向こうは敵と思ってないんだから
もう冷静に平和でいる
しかし 私もあいつは大敵だと思っているし
向こうも私が大敵だと思っていると
これはもう もう必ずお互いにひどいことをするんですね
落ち着いていることはできないんです
ヴェーリワパナヴェーリナン
ヴェーリっていうのは怒りの人と
この場合 憎しみですね
憎しんでる人はまた憎しみ同士で
私がある人のことを憎んでいるし
その人は私のことを憎しんでる場合ね
憎しみ同士なんですね
どうするでしょうかと
それで終わります その一行と二行は
どうするでしょうかね
これはもう想像に任せるんです
大敵同士で ものすごい互いに憎しみ合ってる場合はどうなると思いますかと
とにかく破壊するでしょう
だから平和の機会 期間
機会というか ひとかけらもその場合はないんですよ
例えば北朝鮮は一方的に日本は敵だと思っている時は
日本人がそう思ってないならば
まあゆっくりゆっくりでも平和になる可能性はあります
やがてでも平和になる見込みだけでもあり得る
それで北朝鮮も日本はもう大敵だと
敵国やと思っていて 日本も北朝鮮は日本の大敵国だと思っていると平和になるんですかね
話し合いもしないでしょうに
何かしたら それは互いを壊すためのことをするんです
だから両側同じ敵視するように敵
敵でいる場合は もう もう手上げ
何の見込みもないんです
破壊するということは確実
その状況を考えてほしいと
だからその一行目の意味はごく自然に理解できないと
二行目の意味はわからなくなっちゃうんです
結局は仏教がわからないということは
一行の意味さえもわかってないでしょうね
世の中で 敵同士の場合は
そこを考えてもないでしょうに
考えたこともないと思いますけど
だからまあもう私は誰かが敵だと思ったっても
相手がそう思ってないっていうことはいくらでもあるんですね
その場合も不幸にはなったり
喧嘩したりはするんですが
やっぱりもうなんとか頑張って
時間かけてでもなんとか見込みぐらいでもありますけど
見込みもゼロですね お互い同じ敵になってしまったところで
互いに恨んだり憎しんだりすることになっちゃうと
もう平和が成り立ちません
必ず確実に不幸になる
確実に破壊する だから確実
百パーセント確実っていうこと
それでミッチャーパニータン・チッタン
間違った方向へ思考すると
心を育てると 心を育てるということは
何か訓練することですから
調教することだから 心というのは我々をいろんなものに調整していくんですよ
例えば運転できるようになったっていうことは心の調整なんですね
心はある方向へ育てたら
もう運転できるようになる
体あったからといって運転できるわけじゃないんです
何でも心の調整なんですよ
何かできるっていうことは
絵を描ける人はもうそれで心を調整するんです
心を調整したところで絵を描ける
ただ手で絵を描いているんだからって
手さえあれば絵を描けるんだぞとか
のはみんな言いたいかもしれませんだけど
それは事実ではありません
手があっただけで絵は描けるわけじゃないんです
絵の作法技術を学ぶということで心の訓練をしていますよ
修行しているんですよ
心を 心が修行しているんだから
そこで修行を進んだところで
もうちゃんとその部分は絵は
絵は描けられる どんなものの場合も心の調教なんです
政治学やら経済学やら何学何を学んでも
人が何ができるのに何でもいいんだから何ができるようになったっていうことで場合は
もうそれは心の調教なんですね
心を育てているんです
だから我々は常にいろんな分野に置かれて心を育てているんです
[背景音楽]そういう一時的な育ちっていうのは
もう日々磨かないと能力は低下する
別なことをやっちゃうと
もう誰も心は巨大に育ててないんだから
ものすごくグニャグニャのほんのちょっとで壊れる心でしょうに
だからあまりにも弱すぎでしょうし
だからすごい弱すぎ心だから
何かちょっと訓練して何かできるようになったら
それから日々磨いておかないとすぐ忘れちゃうんです
日々別な何かやってますからね
だから日々修行しない
磨かないということはかなりの問題なんです
例えば ある五年間数学を学んだとする
で それ頭がすごいしっかりはしていますけど
それから辞めたとしたら
もうその人は死んだわけじゃないでしょうに
五年でそれを辞めたんですから
その日から別なことをやってるでしょ
仕事をしたり 何とかやったりはしています
それはその人の別な訓練になってるんです
それで心がもともと弱いんだから
あの五年間の訓練というのはそのまま消えてしまうんです
心は別なねじ曲がりに変わっちゃうんですね
だから訓練 修行っていうのは
やっぱりこの常に磨いておかないと忘れるっていうのはごく普通なことなんです
忘れてこなければ もともと心そのものをしっかりと強化しておかないと
いわゆる器が大きかったらね
あとは 1本の針金しか持ってない人は
その針金でいろんな作品を作ると 1本しか持ってないんだったら
これでじゃあ蝶々を作りましょうと
次に では花を作りましょうちゃうと
また蝶々の針金をまた伸ばして
また花にせなくちゃあかんでしょう
そうすると蝶々はもうないんですね
もし長い長い針金を持ってるんだったら
じゃあこちらで蝶々で
こちらで花で こちらでもうみかんとかこちらであれとか
いくらでも作れます その場合は勉強したものは忘れられないんです
だから昔は勉強してたのに
今はさっぱり忘れてるんだと言ったら
これはもうcapacityの問題で
そういうことで 我々は心の訓練するということは本当は毎日やってます
毎日心の訓練やってますけど
それって何の役にも立たないし
偉くなるわけでもないんです
毎日やってることやっても
こんな弱い心でね その場でその場でなんとかしたからといって
次のことをやると 元のはもう跡形もなく消えているんです
だから短い針金でじゃあ蝶々を作ったと
それは蝶々でよかったと
では次に花を作ってくださいと言っても
もう蝶々はないんだからね
それでいつでも 1個の作品しか持ってないでしょうに
1本しか持ってないんだから
器は小さいんだから そういうわけで
我々は日々何かを訓練はしていますけど
その用が済んだらそれで終わっちゃってしまうんです
役に立たない だからこの世の中でプロとプロでない人ってあり過ぎでしょ
自慢もしてますね 日本は何でもプロ主義なんです
各分野でプロなんですね
野球にいたってもプロがいて
で アマチュアもいて 全くできない人もいるし
で ワープロだったらプロがいて
アマチュアもいて 全くできない人もいるとか
どんな分野でもプロ ラーメン屋だったってもやっても
これはまたプロやとあれ自慢げに言うんですけど
みんな忘れてますよ これは能力ないということは大げさに言っていることなんです
それいう分capacityが小さいんだと
これしかできないんだよと言っていることなんですよ
裏返してみると ラーメン屋で一人前に
一人前にでしたっけ 一人前になるためには
私はもう六年 なんとか何とか何とかところで修行したんだと
それからどうでしょうかって言ったら
でも本当のこと 私はものすごい情けないほど能力ないっていうことをね
言っているのは 五年修行を積んだとかね
八年修行を積んだとかね
どういったことをフランス料理を習ったと
十年もかけてとかね だからプロにならなきゃ仕事にならない世界ですよ
当然 そんなにもプロを自慢するならば
ずいぶん頭が悪いということは
ものすごいもっと何倍も大きい声で言ってるんです
で 調べてください このプロを自慢している人々は
その世界以外は何も知らないでしょうに
野球のプロ選手たちっていうのは
それしか何もできない
だから これは心のキャパシティの問題
だからプロになるということは誰にでもできますよ
何か一つ決めて それだけずっとやり続ければ
もうその心はその通りになる
しかし 別なことをやらしちゃっちゃうとダメなんです
もう一流のクックさんになった人に
ではあんた絵も描いてみてくださいと
言うと その人は一流のクックさんになるために
もしかすると六 八年かかったのかもしれませんでしょ
そうすると では絵を描きましょうと思ったところで
また六 八 七 八年かかります
それでどうなるのかというと
一応クックさんの腕が落ちるか
いくら頑張っても絵を描けないか
どちらかです で それで世の中で我々すごいこの褒め称えているこの天才的な人物いるでしょうに
あの人々はいくつかのことできるでしょうに
一つってわけじゃない
例えばアインシュタインにしても
ものすごく性格も優しくて
えらい冗談も言ったり
ふざけたり いろいろなことをやっていると
普通の人間としても結構もう場を明るくしてあげて
それもできると 自分の分野になってくるとものすごい
またすごいし それでバイオリンも弾くしとか
なんとかとかね それで人間論もまた語っているとかね
まあいろいろなことできる
どちらにでもなかなかなものでしょう
アインシュタインも頭が良かった
相当いろいろ買ってたんです
あの人間に人間について語っているものはくだらないとかね
言えないでしょ あれはやっぱりキャパシティが大きいっていうことははっきりしているんです
それで私が言いたいのは
我々はどんな人間でも何かを心の訓練はしているが
これが全然今一応役に立たない
そこそこに役に立つ場合は
何か仕事絡みのものを何かね
そればっかりやるしかないんです
わがまま文句言わないで
つまらないとか何とかと言わないで
自分の仕事絡みの世界でじーっとやるしかないんです
一生かけて だってしょうがないです
能力なく生まれたんだから
プロでなきゃもう誰も仕事を頼まないでしょうに
アマチュアに仕事を頼むわけないでしょうに
ハサミを取れるハサミで切れるぐらいだけの人に誰が散髪頼むんですかね
やっぱりプロに頼むんですよ
そういうことで それで
もし私たちが間違った方向へその心を育てたら
どうなるのかというと
あの敵同士で何かするでしょう
憎しみ同士だったら何がするでしょうと
それよりもひどいこと
自分の心が自分にするんだよと
だから心は間違うこと
心の方向転換が脱線すること
この世の中である一番最強の恐ろしい危険なことなんです
軽く見るものじゃないんですよ
心なんかへっちゃらや
それよりは世間では人気者になった方がありがたいのではないかとかね
そんなものじゃないんです
だから 敵だったらね もうせいぜいできることっていうのは自分を殺すことでしょ
それ以上ひどいな ひどいことできんだからね
例えば自分の家族を殺したと
家族を殺しても自分が生きているんだからね
それで残された自分が堂々と世界で成功していると
敵が別にもう勝ったことにならんでしょうに
だから敵だったら一番できる一番怖いことといえば殺すぐらいでしょ
でも心が間違ったらそれでは止まりません
間違った心があると毎日間違ったことをする
毎日悩みハメになる 毎日苦しいことを味わう羽目になる
ほんのちょっと心の回転間違ったら
それで精神的に病気にもなったりして
またもう治らない もう治りますけど
そこ世間では治療方法はない
みんな指つぼの写真だから
何かいい薬ないのかと
そればっかしで 脳活性化するすごいいい薬がありましたとかね
昨日読んだ新聞記事であったのは
ビタミンE飲むと死ぬんだよと
ものすごい危険だとテストをやってるからね
このちょっと 1週間前読んだ医学的な記事で
やっぱりこの この なんて言います
みんなこの補助的にあらゆるビタミンとかなんとか飲んでますけど
健康や健康やとか言ってね
これはこの一つの まあなんて信仰ではないか
迷信ではないかと 本当のところものすごい逆効果ではないかと
いうところにそれなりのデータがありましたけど
まあ昨日の記事では このビタミンEっていうのは取るもんじゃないんだと
もう考え直した方がいいんだと
アメリカで決まってる 1 日の摂取量決まってあります
イギリスはまた別な もっと低いんですけど
これはどちらでもあまりにも高すぎやと
1 日の摂取するべき量っていうのはものすごい高すぎやと
そこは必ず減らして これただの発表ですからね
で それに適した もしそこは摂取していないならば
まあそれぐらいした方がいいと
それに反論もありますけど
テストに使ったのは全部この合成物
合成ビタミンでしょうと
しかし 自然の食べ物から取るものは違うんじゃないかなとか
それまた意見だけであって
そこはちょっとまだテストしてないんです
でしかしサントリーがなんかセサミンなんとかいいとかなんとかとかね
発見しましたと これこそなんとかすごい宣伝して売ってますけどね
だから １粒飲んだらごま 3000粒の成分が入ってるんだと
おそらく人殺しの毒を売っているかもしれません
でも信仰と科学っていうのは
信仰と迷信っていうのは決まってるんだからね
ただ ビタミンEはこういうこういう機能していますよと
例えば皮膚がものすごく美しくしてくれるとかね
若々しくしてくれるとかね
まあ確かにそうやってくれる
では取ろうっていうと
違うんだと そこででは取りましょうということで
バンバンE取ったりする
ビタミンEというのはあの
油性というんですか 油に
何でしたっけ 油性ですね
これ体に留まるんですよ
留まって腐るんだそうです
だから水性だったらもうもう尿と流しちゃいますから
体に残らないんです これはあっちこっち止まっちゃって
これで腐って毒に変わるんだと
かなり死を早めるんだと
まあ四十五 十歳といたらもう
そこで最後に書いたのは
このマルチビタミンなんか取ってるならば
気をつけろと ビタミンEは入ってるんだからね
そこでアメリカが決まってる一日の量が入ってるんです
その上食べたりもするでしょうし
人間はもう一応もう体ばっかり体中心にばっかり考えてるんですからね
まあまあしょうがないんですけど
で そういう風に毒を飲んでも
まあせいぜい体が壊れて死ぬだけの結果で
そんな大胆な結果じゃないんです
しかし 心が間違っちゃうと
もう切りがなく不幸になるんだっていうこと
これで肉体は一回で終わっちゃうでしょうね
心っていうのは続くんだからね
このティスサ長老のエピソードを見てもね
もうものすごい もうもう想像を絶する遠い昔
もう動物を殺しただけのことで
これがずっと心に染みついて
不幸にして そして最後に悟る時
最後でもたった残ったもので
まあ残ったものとは言わない
あの場合は ただね まあこの付着しただけの匂いでも
あれぐらい酷いものになっちゃったんだから
もしティスサ長老が何かもう自然のことで皮膚病になったりしたならば
すぐ簡単に治ります これは治療は効かない
治療はなし 存在もしない
業から出てきた病気だから
[咳]医者が診たってもわからないというだけで
わからないと言ったらかっこ悪いんだから
なんとか病名 病名をつけてくれる
病名つけたっても何の意味もないんです
バカバカしい 筋肉は縮む病とかなんとか
だから何よと そんなことは言わなくなっても診たらわかるんだから
だから心が悪い場合でも
特に心理学の世界でも
病名って 名っていうのはあるはあるはあるはもうえらいかっこつけて訳の分からない病名をつけたりつけたけど
私は聞きたいのはあんた方治療法を持ってるのかと
それは持ってないんですね
だからもう世の中ではもう体だけ偉いと思ってるんだから
心が病気になるともう終わったとした方がいいんです
治療法の世界ではないんです
だからなんとか薬見つけた
薬見つけた 薬見つけたとか
あれがとんでもない嘘ということになっちゃうんですね
だから ビタミンは体にすごくいいやと言っても
これは今の研究から見れば嘘でしたと
今言ってることは 後の研究から見てもっと嘘でしたと
ずっと騙されっぱなしでしょうに
そんなことないますよ
体こそ唯一な存在であると思ってるんだから
だから仏教は全くも違う立場で
心こそすべての支配している存在機能であるという立場では言ってる
だから育てるべきなのは心なんですね
だから 敵同士で会うよりも
我が心が変になっちゃうと危険であるということはものすごい恐怖感で感じないと
危ないんだと 自分の心はちょっと間違ったら何するかわからないぐらいすごい危険物やと
危険視しないと心を調教することはできないんですね
軽々く生半可な気分で心を調教しようとか
できるものじゃないんです
もう危ないんだと だって心に怒りがついたら
これは人にバレなくてはいいんじゃないかと
そんな甘くない バレなくてもバレなくなっても
自分の心 怒り持ってるんだから
次は破壊行為に行くんです
だから心は勝手ですから
自己管理できんでしょうに
ずいぶんわがままっていうのは心がわがままなんです
話聞かないのは心なんです
言っても言っても理解しないのは心なんです
肉体じゃないんです 外の影響はもろに受けるのは心なんです
体じゃないんですよ 体は別にただの物質だからね
結構しぶといんですよ
心はそうじゃないんです
すぐ影響を受けちゃう
ちょっと寒くなったんだからといって
別に死ぬわけないでしょうに
気が弱い人は まああれやこれやと言うだけの話で
心が弱いんだったら ちょっともう天気
温度が下げただけでも
もうすごいひどい目に遭う
肉体はそんなにも弱じゃない
別にもう自然なものでね
それなりにしぶといんですけど
だからほんのちょっとでも
だから心っていうのはもう大変なもので
もうもうわがままで話は聞いてくれない
言っても言っても理解してくれない
ずいぶん勝手なんですね
それは明らかに我々の生き方を見ると見えるでしょうに
怒りたくない 怒りたくない
だったらなんで怒るのかと
余計な欲が良くないんだと知ってますよと言いながらやってるでしょうに
だからあの矛盾って何なのかと
例えば嘘をついてはいけない
それは当たり前でしょうと言いながら嘘をつくでしょうに
矛盾でしょうに その矛盾どこにあるんですかね
それ心なんですよ だから心は自分の勝手で自分決めたパターンでいくんだから
幸せの方向にはいけない
これもエネルギー法則だから
俺が幸せになってやるぞと思ったって
エネルギー持ってないと
持ってるエネルギーで次の行為するでしょうに
それが悪いものだったら悪いことになってしまうんです
だから心に怒りが溜まったとする
怒りが溜まっても 私は幸せになってやるぞと思って
するでしょうね それでエネルギー使わなくちゃいかんでしょう
持ってるエネルギーは持っていたエネルギーそのものは怒りだから
次に破壊ということの結果になるんです
それは避けられないんです
だから ものすごい危ないものっていうのは
自分の心であるっていうことは
まあ理解して すごい危険なものであると
これが捕まってきちんと管理できるようになったら
これほどすごいことはないんです
例が悪いんですけども
ウランでもプルトニウムでもね
ものすごいもう徹底的に危険なものでしょうし
これが完璧に管理できれば
もうこれほどいいことないでしょうに
エネルギーの問題なくなっちゃいますから
まあその場合物質だから完璧に管理っていうのは成り立ちません
ありえない まあとにかくそういう例ででも考えるしかないんです
また お釈迦様時代で このアナーターピンディカ居士のまあ仕事をしていた
このあるナンデという名前のこの牛飼いがいたんだと
その人は牛の監督で もう彼がまあ牛の面倒を見て
その収入で生活をしているんです
で 昔インドでは牛があるということは大変贅沢というかね
だって牛乳やらね 牛乳からあらゆる食べ物を作れますから
それはもう最高のごちそうだと思っていたんですね
とにかくそれほど肉 肉食べる文化でもなかったんだから
もう野菜ばっかり食っていたんですから
やっぱりそこに乳製品が入ってくると
もうかなり豪華に感じるんです
それで彼がもうアナーターピンディカ尊者にも時々もうすごくいいものが出来上がっちゃうと
いい牛乳やらヨーグルトやらもうね
チーズやらいろいろできたところで
まあ持っていってあげたりして
で アナーターピンディカ尊者と一緒にお釈迦様にも会って説法を聞いたりもするんだと
そこでお釈迦様に会うたびに自分が随分遠いところに住んでいるんです
アナーターピンディカ居士のところに来るのは
もうそれなりに時々なんです
その時はもう大量にいろんなものを持ってきて
その時ちょっとお釈迦様にも会ったりする
お釈迦様にも会うたびに自分が住んでいるところにも一度いらっしゃってくださいとお願いする
お釈迦様はじゃあそのうちっていうことにするんです
では行きましょうとはしないんです
それでお釈迦様に何回何回も会って会って会って会って説法を聞いて
ある日お釈迦様が じゃあ今行かなくちゃっていうことに決めたんです
お釈迦様はいつでもこの何主義者ですかね
いつでも結果主義者だからね
ただ会ってどうお元気ですか？とかね
ちょっと挨拶して説法して帰るという無駄なことはやりたくないんです
で 毎日説法を聞いて悟る人がいるんだから悟る順番なんですね
今日悟る人には今日説法する
明日悟る人だったら もう今日はいくら説法してくださいっても
明日にしますということになるんです
だから このナンダさんも
お釈迦様を紹介してもしても
お釈迦様が言わなかったんです
それでじゃあ行きましょうということで
比丘たちと一緒にその人のところに行ったんです
なぜかというと その人はもうかなり心ができちゃって
もう悟られるということで
ただ 1週間そちらで泊まっていて
もうこの人は 1週間お釈迦様にお布施をして
もう大変説法も聞いて
もう終わったら ではもう帰りますということで
お釈迦様は帰ることになったんです
それでこの人はお釈迦様を見送りしなくちゃいけないんだから
お釈迦様の鉢を自分で持って
上にかける衣も両方もうすごい丁寧に頭の上に乗せて
お釈迦様の後ろから行くんです
で 結構遠くを行くんです
お釈迦様は村から出ていく
比丘たちも後ろから来る
この人はお釈迦様の鉢と衣を頭に乗せて
もう丁寧に持って後ろから行く
かなり村から離れたところで
お釈迦様はもう君止まりなさいと
ここら辺で 言ったらもう鉢と衣を渡して返してあげて
お釈迦様に礼をして止まったんです
止まってもう帰ろうとしてもう帰るんです
帰ると あの藪からいきなり矢が飛んできて
さっと刺さっちゃったんです
そのまま倒れたんですよ
で 後ろのお坊さんたちがそれを見たんですね
もう死んだ 死んで 死には死ぬことないんですけど
まあもうそれで死にますからね
でお釈迦様にこれ言ったんです
お釈迦様はなんであの時あの人を帰せちゃった
帰したんですかと もうちょっと前とかね
あるいはもうちょっと行ったところでとかね
帰したあの戦術なんか知らないでしょうと
でお釈迦様は今日はね
私が来ても来なくても
その人は死ぬんだよと
同じやり方で 彼がもう
東西南北とか八方ありますね
これどこへ行っても今日は死にますと
ただ単にもう私の後ろから来て
私はもう帰させたんだからって
それで死んだわけじゃないんだよということなんです
だから まあそれはその人の心にあった業で
まあこれはもう誰にもどうすることもできない
だから心にそういう業が入っていると
もう誰にも手を出すことはできない
敵同士で喧嘩するんだったら
第三者にも間に入りますけどね
自分の心が攻撃すると間に入る人はいないんだからね
そこでお釈迦様はそれを知った上でその日にち決めたんです
で 1週間も付き合ってあげて
説法してあげて 彼が夜中に悟り開いたんです
だから悟れるんだっていうとこになったところで言って説法して
だから別に人生は失敗したわけじゃないんです
悟りましたからね 第1番目にステージに夜勤っていうところに
だからお釈迦様から見れば
別にあの人はブッダに会って
それですぐ不幸になったんではなく
そうじゃなくてそれで良かったんではないかと
どうせその日は死にますよと
でもお釈迦様は自分の慈悲で考えて
もうこの日で死ぬんだから
じゃあもっと先に行ってその人を悟らせてあげちゃえば
まあそれで成功やと そういうことで
敵が敵にやることよりもひどいことは
曲がったねじ曲がった心が自分自身にあるんだよということ
言葉になっています はい
話は終了します どうもありがとうございます
すいません ちょっと質問よろしいですか
42頁の前半のところにヤンタンカイラーのタンですけども
このタンっていうのは後半にありますパーリ語の比較対象として捉えた方がいいのか
あるいはヴィサン・ベーディガンのことを言ってるのか
ヤンカイラタンでしょ
ヤンタンカイラっていうのは分析するとヤンカイラタン
タンの次にまたもうカイラ入らなくちゃいけないんですけど
それはカレーなんですね
でもそこはもう使ってないんですね
ディサン デイリナンのタンと
それからパーティウォの比較対象になるタンと二つのという意味ですか
それは意味が多当ものすごい違いますからね
多当っていうのはそれよりって意味になりますから
タンになったら同じことになりますよ
多当というのは多当パランという言葉なんです
それよりもやっちゃいますよと
それよりも それはそのタンというふうに考えていいんですか
ん？ あしきことといいますか
ヤンにタンは繋げなくちゃいけないんですけど
まあここではもう もう多当という言葉を入れてますから
普通のチャンジュンパーリ語で出てくるものとは少々違うんです
本当はタンと多当両方心にかかってます
ヤンカイラー タンカイラーとせなくちゃいけないんです
ディソーディサンヤンカイラーミッチャーパニヒチャンチッタンタンカイラーという風にせなくちゃいけないんですね
そうすると同格なんですね
敵は敵にするものが 心が自分にするんだよと
でもそれでは足らんと
もっとひどいやという場合は
痛いながら多当という言葉を入れてたんですね
だから普通 まあまあそんなもんで
別に複雑な文章ってわけじゃないんですけど
そうしますと このタンはディサンとかデイリナンに相当すると考えてよろしいですか？ タンは置いてますよ
置いてる  置いてます うん
だから多当取っちゃえばもうぴったしなんでしょ
多当はないと思っちゃえば
タンは見事に下の文章につなげるです
うん だから多当というものはまず削除して分析してみると
文章はぴったしなんです
タン下に持ってくると
ミッチャーパニヒタンチッタンタンカレーと
ヤンカイラータンカレーでしょ
それでバランスでしょ
うん  はい それで「多」と入れてる 「
単」ではなくて「多当」だよと
それよりもひどいだよと
やんたんあっちゃうとイコールだからね
まあ文法から見れば多当には「ば」がないんですが
意味から言うと多当は入れたいんですよ
多当を入れたいんだから
やっぱり単は浮いてるんです
詩を作った人にとっては多当を入れたいんだからね
しかしやんあったら単がないとね
もうちょっとバランス崩れちゃうし
成り立たないし 単は入れたんですけど
使ってないんです  はい
それからあの 先ほどのお話で
ナーガールジュンパが矢に撃たれた時に
あの弟子がですね  アンテクニじゃなくて
ナーンダサンガ  それで
あの お弟子さんがお釈迦様に意見するといいますか
ちょっと言い方悪いんですけど
非難するような言い方に聞こえたんですけども
そういうのってなんかちょっと失礼な言い方に聞こえたんですけど
そういうことあった？